Matthew Garber played the younger bank's
child Michael in the original Mary
Poppins and was only eight years old
when he took the role the eldest of two
boys Garber began acting with the
encouragement of Shakespearean actor Roy
Dotrice garba's film debut came in
Disney's the three lives of Thomasina
when casting directors fell in love with
the boy's fun exuberant personality
after Mary Poppins Garber starred in a
final Disney film
1967's the snowmobile in 1976 a 21 year
old Garber caught hepatitis while
traveling through India although he
returned to the United Kingdom for
treatment it was too late and the
disease had affected his pancreas on
June 13 1977 Matthew Garber died of
complications from hepatitis